.
* Schniefen *
Ich will zu dir nach Hause.
Ich habe Angst, alles zu verlieren.
* Herzpochen *
Nein, du kannst uns nie verlieren.
* Schniefen *
Die Frau, die ich meiner Mutter
vorstelle, werde ich heiraten.
Ich erzähle ihr immer Witze
und ich erwarte eine Reaktion.
Aber da kommt jeweils nur:
"Ja, das war lustig."
Das stimmt, ich lache nicht über
seine Witze, obwohl sie gut sind.
Ich habe vieles für die Liebe
aufgegeben, eigentlich alles.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
# Forever you and me.
* Herzpochen *
* Veloklingel *
* Sanfte Musik *
(Liebe fragt nicht nach dem Pass.)
(Und auch nicht, ob man gerade
andere Pläne im Leben hatte.)
(Soll eine binationale Liebe
funktionieren,
braucht es radikale Entscheide.)
Es war ein Auto, das dafür sorgte,
dass Juan, ein Spanier,
und Simona, eine Schweizerin,
in Italien wohnen.
Allerdings nicht dieses hier.
Ich sah Simona in einen Nachtklub.
Ich sprach sie an
und lud sie zu einem Drink ein.
Und da sind wir!
(Ich treffe Simona und Juan
in der Altstadt von Modena.)
Darf ich mich zu euch setzen?
- Sicher, sicher.
Ich bin Mona.
- Juan.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Hallo, Mona.
(Der Formel-1-Rennstall von Ferrari
ist der Grund,
warum die beiden
in Norditalien gelandet sind.)
(Juan ist Maschineingenieur.)
(Er arbeitet in der Entwicklung
von Formel-1-Motoren.)
War es schon immer dein Traum,
für Ferrari zu arbeiten?
Oh ja, das ist so.
Einmal dort zu arbeiten,
schien mir eigentlich unmöglich.
Ferrari ist weltberühmt.
Schon in den Sommerferien
nach drei Jahren Beziehung
schwärmte er von Ferrari.
Damals war ich entschieden dagegen.
Später sagte ich,
er könne sich ja mal bewerben.
Ich wollte nicht immer
vorab Nein sagen.
Und dann bekam er diese Stelle.
Dann begannen wir,
intensiv zu diskutieren,
abzuwägen, zu überlegen und ...
Hast du dir auch überlegt,
nicht mitzugehen?- Ja.
Ich habe über alles nachgedacht.
Warum hast du dann doch
alles zurückgelassen
und bist für Juan und Ferrari
nach Modena gegangen?
Der ausschlaggebende Punkt war,
dass Juan sagte:
"Ich gehe nicht ohne dich -
nur mit dir."
Da wusste ich, dass er seinen Beruf
nicht über unsere Beziehung stellt.
Alleine wollte er nicht gehen -
nur, wenn ich mitkomme.
(Kennengelernt haben sich die beiden
2010 in Paris.)
(Sie machte einen Sprachkurs
und er arbeitete
bei Renault als Ingenieur.)
(Gut fünf Jahre lang
führten sie eine Fernbeziehung.)
(Olten - Paris und zurück.)
(Aber dann
kamen Italien und Ferrari ins Spiel.)
(An diesem Punkt
mussten sie sich entscheiden.)
Und wo?
Hier drinnen fragte mich Papa,
ob ich ihn heiraten wolle.
Er fragte mich auf Schweizerdeutsch:
"Willst du mich heiraten?"
* Zwei Männer unterhalten sich
auf Italienisch. *
* Ruhige Musik *
Er drückte einem Mann
die Kamera in die Hand.
Er sagte,
dieser Mann mache ein Foto von uns.
Eigentlich
machte dieser aber ein Video.
Dann wühlte er megalang
in seiner Tasche.
Ich dachte: "Steh endlich für
das Foto hin, mach mal vorwärts!"
Ich fragte etwas genervt:
"Was machst du da?"
* Gefühlvoller Popsong:
"Take My Hand" von Adrian Stern
und Martin Villiger *
Als er auf die Knie ging,
dachte ich:
"Jetzt kommt ... Oh mein Gott!"
Er fragte mich:
"Willst du mich heiraten?"
Ich musste mich
auf die bestmögliche Art verkaufen.
Ich dachte, auf Schweizerdeutsch
zu fragen, sei eine gute Idee.
Es hat geklappt.
Sie hat Ja gesagt.
Es freute mich natürlich,
als er schon am Freitag schrieb.
Er fragte, wo ich sei,
ob wir uns wiedersehen könnten.
Normalerweise
schreibt ein Mann nicht vorher.
Wenn er Sonntag sagt,
dann am Sonntag, nicht vorher.
Und als er dann schrieb,
freute ich mich natürlich.
* Lockere, heitere Musik *
(Angefangen hat alles auf Tinder.)
(In den Ferien auf Hawaii
schaute Fabienne aus dem Glarnerland
sich auf der Dating-App um,
was für Männer
man hier treffen könnte.)
Baby boy.
(Und sie fand Francis.)
Ich war hin und weg
von seinem Profilfoto auf Tinder.
Er sah so süss
auf diesem Bild aus.
Das zog mich an.
Es machte Klick.
Ich mochte ihr blondes Haar
und ihren Hintern.
(Und es stimmte - neben Haar
und Hinterteil - auch der Humor.)
* Lockere, heitere Musik *
Bevor ich Fabienne traf,
konnte ich
gar nicht richtig schwimmen.
Wir gingen schnorcheln.
Ich hatte Angst, schwimmen zu gehen.
Um nicht unterzugehen,
kaufte ich mir ein BuggyBoard.
Er sagte mir nicht,
dass er Angst hat.
Ich wollte ihr natürlich
nicht zeigen, dass ich Angst hatte.
* Lockere, heitere Musik *
(Dass aus dieser Ferienromanze
mehr werden könnte,
war für Fabienne bald klar.)
(Ganz im Gegenteil zu Francis.)
(Trotz der schönen Zeit
sah er keine gemeinsame Zukunft.)
Als ich sie zum Flughafen brachte,
sagte ich ihr,
sie solle mich nicht mehr anrufen.
Sie aber meinte,
dass sie wiederkommen werde
und dass unsere Liebe
eine Chance hätte.
Als sie dann in der Schweiz war,
versuchte ich,
nicht an sie zu denken.
Es ging so weit,
dass ich sie nicht mehr anrief.
Ich wollte nicht wieder Liebeskummer
wegen einer Fernbeziehung haben.
Aber dann kam sie zurück,
und all die Gefühle
kamen wieder hoch.
Ich bin froh, dass sie zurück ist.
(Alles oder nichts
hiess es für Fabienne und Francis.)
(Und die beiden
setzten voll auf Risiko.)
(Knall auf Fall
verabschiedete sich Fabienne
vom Glarnerland
und ihrem Job als Sachbearbeiterin
und folgte ihrem Herzen.)
(Schon ein paar Monate später
heirateten sie.)
(Heute leben die beide
im Makiki-Viertel von Honolulu,
nur 10 Min. vom legendären
Waikiki-Strand entfernt.)
(Francis' Eltern sind Filipinos,
die in den 80er-Jahren
in die USA einwanderten.)
(Er selbst wurde auf Hawaii geboren.)
So, wer kann schneller und besser
Lumpias rollen?
Nein, das ist kein Wettbewerb.
Für mich ist es das erste Mal,
dass ich mit einer Partnerin
zusammenlebe.
Ich lebte nie
mit einer Freundin zusammen.
Für mich ist es auch das erste Mal.
Ich war v.a. oft auf Reisen.
Darum hatten wir immer
eine Frauen-WG mit Mami.
Das war eigentlich
am besten für mich.
Ich konnte verreisen,
wann ich wollte,
und es war immer jemand da,
der zur Wohnung schaute.
Die ist perfekt.
(In dieser Frauen-WG
der Familie Kaiser im Glarnerland
muss etwas Ansteckendes
im Umlauf gewesen sein.)
(Fabiennes jüngere Schwester
packte ein paar Monate später
auch die Koffer
und wanderte in die USA aus -
nach San Francisco.)
(Und auch sie: wegen der Liebe.)
Irgendwie haben sie es erwartet,
aber sie waren schon recht traurig,
v.a. meine Mutter.
Sie hatte mich und meine Schwester
immer im Haus,
und dann gingen wir beide
Knall auf Fall.
Mit 21 sagte ich meinem Vater:
"Ich habe  d e n  Mann getroffen."
Und mein Vater:
"Du bist 21, er lebt weit entfernt."
"Der hat doch
bestimmt schon eine andere."
Und ich: "Nein, nein, nein."
* Rockige Klänge *
(Eigentlich wollte Noëlle
nur ein wenig reisen.)
(Auf einem Roadtrip fuhr sie
der Westküste der USA entlang.)
(Doch dann nahm ihr Leben
eine dramatische Wende -
in einem hundsgewöhnlichen Irish Pub
in San Francisco.)
(Dort war Matt zu Besuch.)
(Und es war Liebe
auf den ersten Blick.)
* Entspannte Musik *
One, two and three.
(Anders als ihre Schwester Fabienne
liess sich Noëlle Zeit
mit dem Umzug.)
(Drei Jahre führten Matt und sie
eine Fernbeziehung.)
Letztes Mal
habe ich drei Wale gesehen.
Wow, ich habe hier
noch nie einen Wal gesehen.
Die waren da draussen.
Drei von ihnen,
zwei grosse und ein Baby.
Crazy.
- Mhm.
This is one of my favorite spots.
Ich habe noch nie jemanden
wie Matt getroffen.
Er hat ein riesengrosses Herz.
Und er will immer,
dass es einem gut geht.
Er ist vielleicht
nicht so offen wie ich.
Er zeigt seine Gefühle
nicht so extrem wie ich.
Aber wenn er jemanden
ins Herz schliesst, dann für immer.
Ich habe so viele Dinge
von ihm gelernt,
die mir gar nicht bewusst waren.
Er machte mich
zu einem besseren Menschen.
Natürlich,
es gibt es immer Probleme im Leben.
Aber die Liebe hilft bei allem,
da man alles teilen kann.
(Noëlle und Matt mussten viele Klip-
pen umschiffen, um zusammen zu sein.)
(Was sie noch nicht wissen:
Ein grosser Test
steht ihnen kurz bevor.)
* Herzpochen *
Ich war nicht auf der Suche.
Ich war am Anfang
auch sehr skeptisch.
Ich dachte,
es ist eine ganz andere Kultur,
ich bin noch nicht so lange
in Afrika, will ich das wirklich?
Ich war zurückhaltend,
im Gegensatz zu ihm.
* Peppige Klänge *
(Ihre Kulturen
sind komplett unterschiedlich,
aber sie haben das gleiche Ziel.)
(Myriam und Chris möchten heiraten.)
Gefällt es dir?
- Ich liebe es.
Mein Land ist einfach nur flach.
Hier ist das Gras immer grün.
Hier ist es auch nicht staubig,
das ist ein grosser Unterschied.
(Chris aus Sambia
ist zum ersten Mal in der Schweiz.)
Here you can see
traditional swiss clothes.
You're supposed to yodel.
(Beide arbeiten für eine gemein-
nützige Organisation in Sambia.)
(Während den Ferien in der Schweiz
wohnen sie bei Myriams Eltern
im Thurgau.)
So.
Ich habe dir wenig Rösti gegeben,
weil du keinen Käse magst.
En Guete miteinander.
- En Guete.- En Guete.
(Chris) En Guete.
Das schmeckt gut -
sogar sehr gut.
That's good.
Bei unserem ersten Treffen warst du
sehr nervös. Nicht wahr, Chris?
Ja.
Oh ja, ich war sehr nervös,
geradezu ängstlich.
(Leben wollen die beiden
vorderhand in Sambia.)
(Trotzdem soll Chris auch
einen Bezug zur Schweiz bekommen.)
Ich mag es,
dass es hier so ruhig ist.
Ja.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Mir ist wichtig, dass es ihm
gefällt, auch für die Zukunft.
Wir wissen nicht,
ob wir für immer in Sambia bleiben.
We can head this way.
Das ist unser Haus von hinten
mit den Solarpanels.
So viele Solarpanels.
Ach, hier ist es einfach schön.
- Gefällt es dir?
- Ja.
- That's good.
In der Schweiz
bedeutet es nicht so viel,
wenn man eine Partnerin
mit nach Hause nimmt.
Aber in Spanien stellt man nicht
jeden Partner oder jede Beziehung
den Eltern vor.
Ich habe mir z.B. Wörter notiert,
die mich sympathisch
erscheinen lassen.
Ich notierte, wie man auf Spanisch
"Kann ich helfen?" sagt.
Ich dachte, es wäre super,
wenn ich mit seiner Mutter
in der Küche bin
und ich sie fragen kann:
"Kann ich helfen?"
Solche Dinge.
Das war schlau von mir.
Alles vorauszuplanen,
das ist typisch Simona.
Ich erinnere mich nicht exakt
an diese Situation ...
I was right.
Aber ich kann es mir gut vorstellen,
dass es genau so war.
* Idyllische, südländisch
anmutende Gitarrenmusik *
(Bei den spanischen Schwiegereltern
funktionierte
dieser Trick jedenfalls.)
(Sie schlossen Simona ins Herz.)
(Mittlerweile
sind Simona und Juan selbst Eltern,
von Ella und Ian.)
(Ein spanischer Vater und
eine Schweizer Mutter in Italien.)
Willst du Fleisch?
- (Ian) Nein.
* Ian spricht spanisch. *
Das reicht, merci.
Süss. Je nach Ansprechperson
wechselt er die Sprache.
Ja, er switcht hin und her.
Er weiss, dass Papa kein Deutsch
und ich kein Spanisch verstehe -
zumindest meint er das.
Wieso unterhaltet
ihr euch auf Englisch?
Anfangs sprachen wir französisch,
weil wir uns in Paris kennenlernten.
Ich war dort,
um Französisch zu lernen.
Deshalb musste er mit mir
französisch sprechen.
Das wurde mit der Zeit schwierig.
Er fiel immer zurück ins Englisch
im Gespräch mit mir.
Und ich spreche zwar Französisch,
aber in dieser Sprache kann ich mich
nicht immer treffend ausdrücken.
* Ella schreit,
Ian äfft sie nach. *
Wechselt man die Sprache,
wird man zu einem anderen Menschen.
(So viele Sprachen
bedeuten manchmal ein Durcheinander,
sind aber auch eine Chance, wenn man
als Kind so aufwachsen kann.)
* Italienisches Chanson *
# Amore mio, ti amo.
(Schon in seiner Kindheit in Spanien
drehte sich bei Juan alles um Autos.)
(Und egal, wohin es ihn zieht,
seine Sammlung aus Büchern,
Modellautos und Erinnerungsstücken
muss mit.)
(Zuerst entwickelte er Formel-1-
Motoren für Renault mit,
jetzt für Ferrari.)
(In einer Vitrine
ist sein Autoaltar.)
So what is it here?
Hier habe ich
meine vielen Souvenirs,
Bilder und Unterschriften
von Fahrern.
Das ist der Red Bull von 2010.
Zu dieser Zeit entwickelte Renault
den Motor für Red Bull.
Und wir haben mit diesem Modell
die Weltmeisterschaft gewonnen.
Das ist der Motor und unser Team.
Ich habe schöne Erinnerungen
an diese Zeit.
(Und es hat ein persönliches Stück
in seiner Vitrine.)
Eines Tages kam Simona und sagte,
sie hätte ein Geschenk für mich.
Sie gab mir
diesen kleinen Ferrari California,
einen der kleinsten Ferraris,
die es gibt.
Und sie gab mir auch dieses Armband.
"Ein kleiner Ferrari
ist auf dem Weg."
Ich schaute sie an und fragte:
"Bist du schwanger?"
Sie sagte: "Ja."
Sie verstand meine Sprache
und sie machte mich sehr glücklich.
Very happy.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Juan fand bei Ferrari
seinen Traumjob.)
(Und Simona?)
(Eigentlich ist sie Ergotherapeutin.)
(Aber in Italien ihren Beruf
auszuüben, ist schwierig.)
(Das Schweizer Diplom
wird nicht voll anerkannt.)
(Darum gründete sie im Land der Mode
ihr eigenes kleines Label.)
(Sie näht Kinderkleider.)
Als ich im ersten Jahr hier war
und meinen Beruf nicht mehr
ausüben konnte, merkte ich,
wie stark ich mich
mit dieser Rolle identifiziere:
Ich fühlte mich als Ergotherapeutin.
Und hier war ich
nicht mehr Ergotherapeutin,
sondern die Freundin eines Mannes,
der bei Ferrari arbeitet.
Mit dem Muttersein
fand ich dann eine neue Rolle.
Ich wollte sowieso
eine Familie gründen, Mutter sein.
Da ich schon seit fünf Jahren
meinem Beruf nicht mehr nachgehe,
habe ich schon fast vergessen,
dass ich mal Ergotherapeutin war,
obwohl ich den Beruf geliebt habe.
(Trotzdem
hat Simona im Alltag oft Mühe
mit der klassischen
Rollenverteilung.)
* Leichtfüssige,
lockere Gitarrenakkorde *
Du bist wegen ihm hierhergekommen,
hast alles zurückgelassen.
Es gibt ein Ungleichgewicht.
Gibt es Momente,
in denen das schwierig sein kann?
Er sieht das Ungleichgewicht
nicht so.
Ich sah das lange so.
Am Anfang habe ich es ihm unter
die Nase gerieben und vorgeworfen:
"Ich bin wegen dir hierhergezogen
und habe alles zurückgelassen."
Ich dachte,
wenn ich einen Kompromiss mache,
muss er den nächsten machen.
"Ich mache das jetzt,
aber der nächste bist du."- Ja.
(Für Simona ist klar, irgendwann
will sie zurück in die Schweiz.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Herzpochen *
Ich wusste,
dass du auf einem Roadtrip warst.
Ich wusste aber nicht, dass du
am anderen Ende der Welt lebst.
Ich dachte,
vielleicht lebst du in Los Angeles.
Das ist nicht so weit weg,
da kann man hinfahren.
Aber als du sagtest,
es sei die Schweiz,
da dachte ich: "Oh ... Oh Mann."
* Lockere Musik *
(San Francisco - Schweiz,
über 9'000 km Distanz.)
(Einmal über den Atlantik
und quer durch die USA.)
(Dass sie zusammengehören,
wussten beide schnell.)
(Aber auch etwas anderes
war Noëlle klar:
Sie wollte nicht Hals über Kopf
alles zurücklassen.)
(Mit 21 hatte sie eben
ihre Ausbildung abgeschlossen
und wollte erst einmal
Berufserfahrung sammeln.)
(Die Konsequenz:
eine dreijährige Fernbeziehung.)
* Die Musik klingt aus. *
(Flüsternd) Hey. There you go.
- Thank you.
Wenn er seine Meetings hat,
muss ich mich reinschleichen
und darauf achten,
dass mich niemand sieht. Genau.
Hi, Buddy.
(Noëlle machte in der Schweiz
eine Ausbildung zur Kindergärtnerin.)
It's okay, Buddy.
Ich sagte Matt,
dass ich nur komme,
wenn ich meinen Beruf ausüben kann.
Dafür ging ich zur Schule.
Ich wollte mit Kindern arbeiten
und ein eigenes Visum haben,
um nicht abhängig von Matt zu sein.
Ich finde, so lastet weniger Druck
auf unserer Beziehung.
Meine Schule hier in San Francisco
ist die einzige,
die auch Visa ausstellen darf.
Das war eigentlich
meine einzige Chance.
Ich bewarb mich,
und zum Glück hat es geklappt.
Hallo, Anna.
Hey, Alba.
Sehr schön - alle hier.
Schaut mal, Magners ist auch hier.
Magners und Whoopie
sind jetzt beste Freunde.
Whoopie, wie geht es dir denn heute?
(Sie unterrichtet
in einer deutschsprachigen Schule -
jetzt, während des Shutdowns,
von zu Hause aus.)
Geht es dir ta-tü-ta-ta, Whoopie?
(Verfremdete Stimme)
Ta-tü-ta-ta, ta-tü-ta-ta.
Coco ...
Nee, der macht nur Quatsch. Coco!
* Die Kinder lachen. *
Er flog auf den Kopf.
Coco, komm mal her.
Komm mal her.
(Mädchen) Du bist ein süsses Ding.
(Der strenge Shutdown in Kalifornien
bereitet der 27-Jährigen Mühe.)
(Weil sie eingeschränkt ist
und kaum mehr jemanden treffen kann.)
(Noëlle vermisst die Schweiz
je länger desto mehr.)
Ich habe einen sehr engen Kontakt zu
meinen Freunden und meiner Familie.
Wenn ich sie länger nicht treffe,
werde ich fast ein wenig depressiv.
Ja.
(Das Heimweh
plagt Noëlle immer wieder.)
(Matt schenkte ihr deshalb
ein Stück Heimat zum Aufhängen.)
Das bekam ich zu Weihnachten.
Das ist der Klöntalersee -
das war megasüss.
Ja.
* Melancholische Klänge, Herzpochen *
Wenn Mama Freunden erzählt,
dass wir beide nach Amerika gehen,
fragen alle: "Wieso?"
"Du Arme."
Das spricht sich im Glarnerland
schnell herum.
(In Honolulu ist Francis
schon früh auf den Beinen.)
(Lunch einpacken.)
(Mit Hawaii-Bildern wie Surfen und
Tourismus hat Francis nichts am Hut.)
(Er arbeitet an einem Ort, der Hawaii
in einem ganz anderen Zusammenhang
zu weltweiter Bekanntheit verhalf.)
(Francis ist Monteur auf der
Militärbasis von Pearl Harbour.)
Gleich nach der Highschool
ging ich zur Armee.
Ich hatte keine
klaren beruflichen Vorstellungen.
Die Armee ist ein guter Start.
V.a. bieten sie
Stipendien fürs College an.
Man sammelt Lebenserfahrung und
lernt verschiedene Länder kennen.
(Reisen und Länder entdecken hiess
für Francis, in den Krieg zu ziehen.)
Als ich im Militär war,
wurde ich 2009/2010
nach Afghanistan geschickt.
Es war eine sehr beängstigende Zeit
für mich.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob ich überleben werde.
Aber es machte mich auch
zu einem besseren Menschen.
Ich wurde stärker und begann,
an mich zu glauben.
Ich lernte darauf zu vertrauen,
dass es
einen nächsten Tag geben wird.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
In Pearl Harbour
habe ich eine stabile Arbeit.
Ich kann für mich und Fabienne
aufkommen.
Und später auch für eine Familie.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Jung die Welt zu entdecken,
war für Fabienne viel unbelasteter.)
Hi, Gryf.
(Vor ein paar Jahren machte sie
in Hawaii einen Sprachaufenthalt.)
(Als sie später noch mal
auf die Insel in die Ferien kam,
lernte sie Francis kennen.)
* Piepsen *
You're good.
Hi.
* Piepsen *
(Sie arbeitet in Honolulu
in der gleichen Sprachschule,
die sie auch besuchte.)
(Dank der schnellen Heirat
mit Francis
bekam Fabienne nach gut acht Monaten
eine Arbeitsbewilligung.)
How are you?- Fine.
* Piepsen *
(Auf die Greencard,
das unbeschränkte Aufenthaltsrecht,
wartete sie über zwei Jahre.)
(Wie im Film musste sie beim
Einwanderungsamt vorstellig werden.)
Der Beamte
war nicht sehr freundlich.
Er wollte z.B. wissen,
ob wir Safer Sex haben, verhüten.
Ich sass dort und dachte:
"Wie bitte?"
Nicht mal Kollegen fragen mich das.
Er fragt das einfach aus dem Nichts.
(Schliesslich
glaubte man Fabienne doch,
dass sie der Liebe wegen
in den USA bleiben will.)
Ich bin so jemand:
Den Weg, den ich kenne,
so macht man es und so ist es.
Jetzt merke ich,
dass es noch einen anderen Weg gibt.
Am Anfang nervt das.
Aber dann
ist es so eine Bereicherung.
Es ist nicht der richtige Weg,
nur weil man es
schon immer so gemacht hat.
Man bekommt eine Weitsicht,
eine Sicht von aussen,
die man vorher nicht hatte
und die man nicht bekommt,
wenn man immer
in seinem Land gelebt hat.
* Sanfte, einzelne Gitarrenakkorde *
(Auf den ersten Hügeln der Abruzzen,
gut 20 km von Modena,
ist das Castello di Montegibbio.)
(Ideales Ziel
für einen Familien-Sonntagsausflug.)
(Mich beeindruckt
Simonas und Juans Offenheit.)
(Sie machen keinen Bogen
um die schwierigen Themen
einer binationalen Beziehung.)
(Das braucht es wohl,
wenn aus der ersten Verliebtheit
ein Leben werden soll,
das für beide passt.)
Welche Jobmöglichkeiten
gäbe es für dich in der Schweiz?
Die Schweiz hat zwar
keine klassische Autoindustrie.
Aber die Schweiz
hat eine grosse Maschinenindustrie.
Dort gibt es Möglichkeiten.
Aber ihr würdet nur
in die Schweiz ziehen,
wenn du dort einen Job hättest,
richtig?
Der Kompromiss ist,
dass wir in die Schweiz
und nicht an einen neuen Ort gehen.
Aber wir gehen nur in die Schweiz,
wenn sich
eine gute Möglichkeit auftut.
Juans Bedingung ist,
dass er nur dann kommt,
wenn er einen Job hat.
Ja, das ist auch nötig,
sonst überleben wir nicht.
Ich kann arbeiten gehen.
Aber es ist für beide klar,
dass er eine berufliche Zukunft
in der Schweiz haben muss,
damit wir starten können.
Ich kann mir auch sehr gut vorstel-
len, weiter in Italien zu bleiben.
Die Kinder sind noch klein.
Vor der Einschulung
müssen wir uns bewusstwerden,
wo wir
unser Nest aufschlagen werden.
Noch haben wir ein Zeitfenster und
esgefällt mir noch gut in Italien,
ich könnte noch bleiben.
Es bleibt spannend.
- Es bleibt spannend - und offen.
# Take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand ...
# Take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand,
# together we will be,
forever you and me, take my hand.
* Herzpochen *
Am Anfang war es hart.
Wie er Emotionen zeigt.
Ist man einmal durchgedrungen,
weiss man,
dass nie etwas gespielt ist.
Er ist immer ehrlich.
Er gibt mir die Sicherheit,
die ich sonst nie hatte.
Und er sieht so gut aus,
mit seinem Bart.
Es ist immer der Bart.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Trotz Liebe und Glück:)
(Noëlle vermisst ihre Familie
und die vertraute Umgebung.)
(Corona und der Shutdown
machen es noch schwerer.)
(Rausgehen und Freunde treffen
geht nicht mehr.)
(Wegen der Reisebeschränkungen
musste ihre Mutter den Besuch
in San Francisco absagen.)
(Über ein Jahr hat Noëlle ihre
Familie schon nicht mehr gesehen.)
Es war das erste Mal,
dass Noëlle ihre Familie in der
Schweiz so lange nicht sehen konnte.
Das hat ihr sehr zugesetzt.
Ich sagte ihr,
wenn deine Schule einwilligt,
von der Schweiz aus zu arbeiten,
dann buch ein Ticket und flieg heim.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Und genau das hat Noëlle gemacht.)
(Noch weiss niemand
von ihrer Familie,
dass Noëlle im Glarnerland ist.)
(Nur eine Freundin der Mutter
ist eingeweiht.)
So, Susle, komm.
Ich schaue mal nach.
Mich darf sie ja sehen
auf dem Balkon.
(Sie hat Noëlles ahnungsloses Mami
zum Kaffee eingeladen.)
Das ist sie, oder?
Saluti.
Du bist hübsch.
Das ist gut.
- Wirklich? Hoi.
Hey super, das ist gut.
Sie sagte,
ich müsse dir Bescheid geben.
Meili, oder nicht?
- Schau.
* Kreischen *
Oh, nein, komm her.
Oh, nein, was machst du hier?
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Prost zusammen.
Nein.
(Dass gleich beide Töchter innerhalb
eines halben Jahres auswanderten,
war für Susanne Kaiser
nicht einfach.)
Solche Spässe mit mir machen
mit bald 60.
Das kannst du nicht machen.
Als ich das erste Mal zurückkam,
nachdem ich dort war,
war es ganz schlimm für mich.
Daran kann ich mich erinnern.
Ich kam nach Hause und fühlte mich
total verloren meinem Haus.
Es war auch intensiv,
weil ich geschieden bin
und wir zusammengelebt haben.
Wir wohnten zusammen
in einer Frauen-WG.
Aber ich mag es ihnen gönnen,
dass sie ihrer Liebe folgen konnten,
und v.a. versuchen,
dass sie so das Leben
des anderen kennenzulernen.
* Herzpochen *
Myriam ist die erste Frau,
die ich meiner Mutter vorstellte.
In unserer Kultur
ist es nicht üblich,
irgendeine Frau
nach Hause zu bringen.
Für mich war immer klar:
Die Frau, die ich meiner Mutter
vorstelle, werde ich heiraten.
* Rhythmische Musik *
(Nach drei Monaten in der Schweiz
zurück in einem der ärmsten Länder
der Welt.)
(Myriam und Chris sind wieder
zu Hause, in Kabwe, Sambia.)
(Heute sind sie bei der Mutter von
Chris zum Mittagessen eingeladen.)
Hi!
- Hi! How are you?
I'm fine.
Du schaust toll aus.
- Thank you!
Hi!
(Chris und seine Mutter
haben eine enge Beziehung.)
(Er ist der Älteste
von fünf Kindern.)
(Der Vater starb,
als Chris erst zwölf war.)
Come in.
- Ich habe dir etwas mitgebracht.
Oh, thank you! Thank you!
- Es ist für Esther und Tabo.
Kleider für die Hochzeit.
(Die Hochzeit
ist schon in ein paar Tagen.)
Denkst du, das passt?
- Ja, ja, es muss einfach.
Thank you!
- You're welcome.
(Zum Mittagessen gibt es ein Huhn -
ein seltener Luxus.)
Es ist sehr gross.
Ich habe es heute Morgen gekauft.
Wirst du es für uns schlachten?
Das machst du für uns.
Okay, I'm going to kill it for you.
Ich habe schon einige geschlachtet.
Jetzt bist du dran.
Ich hab's schon gemacht.
Ich finde es nicht so schlimm.
(Fast 3 Fr. hat das Prachtexemplar
gekostet - viel Geld.)
(In Sambia verdient man im
Durchschnitt rund 100 Fr. im Monat.)
* Das Huhn gackert. *
You can get it.
- Mmh.
Kommst du mir bitte helfen?
- Ja, ich komme.
In der Schweiz kauft man es einfach.
Der Teil des Schlachtens
wird uns meist nicht gezeigt.
Und auch das Zubereiten
und die Eingeweide ausnehmen
lernt man hier schon von klein auf.
Ich hatte das vorher
auch noch nie gemacht,
darum finde ich es schwierig,
es genau so zu machen,
wie sie es machen.
Werdet ihr das Huhn kochen
oder braten?
Ich weiss nicht.
Myriam, triff eine Entscheidung!
Wir werden es braten.
- Gut, okay.
Nun, da ich alt werde,
übernehmen sie meine Stellung.
Yes.
Sie ist jetzt Mrs Mubengwa.
He's Mr Mubengwa.
Ich übergab ihr den Namen.
In meiner Kultur
ist sie jetzt meine Mutter.
Sie ist Mama Mimi.
Sie ist jetzt meine Mutter.
(In eine Familie
in Sambia einheiraten
heisst auch, die Gesetze
der Gesellschaft zu akzeptieren.)
(Kinder müssen ihre Eltern
unterstützen. Anders geht's kaum.)
(Mama Martha
bekommt weder eine Witwenrente
noch später eine Altersrente -
und das, obwohl Familie Mubengwa
zum Mittelstand gehört.)
Here's the beans.
The chicken was big.
But it's tasty.
- Mhm.
Ich dachte nie, dass ich je
eine weisse Frau heiraten würde.
Ich sah diese Möglichkeit nicht.
Wo würde ich
eine weisse Frau kennenlernen?
Und dann ist es einfach passiert.
Ich bin so froh.
Sie ist einfach bezaubernd.
* Rhythmische Musik *
(Liebe stand nicht auf dem Plan,
als Myriam nach Sambia kam.)
(Die Schweizerin
wollte hier nur arbeiten.)
(Nun wohnen sie und Chris
seit Kurzem zusammen -
im Luangwa-Viertel, das als
bessere Wohngegend von Kabwe gilt.)
(Aber auch dort wäscht man von Hand.)
* Windrauschen *
Fest drücken und reiben.
Mein Vater brachte mir
das Waschen bei.
Wir sind sehr genau,
wenn es ums Waschen geht.
Eine Waschmaschine
kriegt das nicht so gut hin.
Und dann
müssen wir es immer schön bügeln.
Sambier legen viel Wert darauf,
dass immer alles gebügelt wird.
Ich bin nicht unbedingt eine,
die immer alles perfekt bügeln muss.
Aber Chris sagt immer,
ich müsse zurück und es bügeln.
(Die Menschen in Sambia
haben einen starken Familiensinn.)
(Ohne den könnte man
in diesem armen Land kaum überleben.)
Häufig hat eine Familie
noch andere Mitglieder,
nicht nur Vater, Mutter, Kinder.
Meist noch ein Cousin.
Auch bei uns: Silu ist da.
Man muss sich dran gewöhnen,
dass nicht nur die engste Familie
da ist,
sondern dass die ganze Familie dazu-
gehört und immer noch jemand da ist.
Es ist oft so, dass sich die Familie
stark unterstützt.
Auch wenn jemand zur Schule
oder an die Uni geht,
hilft man dieser Person gemeinsam.
Dann ist es oft so,
dass Chris gefragt wird -
weil sie ja weiss ist und genug hat.
Das ist manchmal ...
... schwierig zu handhaben.
(Als Chris mit zwölf
seinen Vater verlor,
stand die Familie vor dem Nichts.)
(Als Ältester musste er die Schule
abbrechen und arbeiten gehen.)
(Später legte seine Familie zusammen
und ermöglichte ihm eine Ausbildung
zum Filmer und Fotografen.)
Ich habe die Batterien
über Nacht geladen.
(Er konnte sogar ein Praktikum
in den USA machen.)
(Myriam studierte in der Schweiz
Wirtschaft.)
(Nach einem humanitären Einsatz
in Afrika, wusste sie:
"Hier will ich leben.")
Mary, wie geht es dir?
(Heute arbeitet sie für eine NGO.)
(Dort hat sie
auch Chris kennengelernt.)
Bist du zufrieden mit dem Laden,
Mary?
Ja, danke. Ich bin zufrieden.
(Vor gut einem Jahr
wurde Mama Mary Geschäftsfrau.)
(Myriam verhalf ihr
zu einem Mikrokredit.)
(Mit 5 ¤ Startkapital
eröffnete sie einen Laden.)
(Sie verkauft Gemüse,
Süssigkeiten und Paraffin.)
(So bringt sie die ganze Familie
und neun Enkel durch.)
(Myriams Organisation
möchte andere auch dazu animieren,
ein eigenes Geschäft zu eröffnen.)
(Darum dokumentieren sie Mama Marys
Erfolgsgeschichte für ihre Webseite.)
Mit ihm muss ich geduldig sein.
Er ist Perfektionist.
Take 1 with Mama Mary.
Action.
Mama Mary, bitte stell dich uns vor!
My name is Mary Piri.
* Entspannte, rhythmische Musik *
* Herzpochen *
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen, Susanne.
Ich bin Mona, freut mich sehr.
Hoi, Mona, freut mich, komm herein.
Da ist Noëlle, hoi,
freut mich, euch zu sehen.
(Im Glarnerland nahm Noëlles
Geschichte eine überraschende Wende.)
Was ist genau passiert, Noëlle?
Am Mittwoch war der Pass in der Post
mit einer Absage.
Mein Visum wurde abgelehnt.
Ich war sofort ...
... völlig entsetzt.
Deine Visumsverlängerung
wurde einfach so abgelehnt?- Ja.
Grund ist der travel ban.
J-1-Teacher - mein Visum -
dürfen momentan nicht einreisen.
Hättestdu das wissen müssen?- Nein,
ich habe alles vorher abgeklärt,
ich wäre gar nicht
in die Schweiz geflogen.
Meine Schule sagte,
es sei kein Problem.
Ich habe nur noch geweint.
(Das Problem: Noëlle und Matt
sind nicht verheiratet.)
(Viele andere machen das für
eine sichere Aufenthaltsbewilligung.)
* Leises Ploppen *
Hi.
- Hi.
Ich werde gerade etwas traurig.
Ich möchte zu dir nach Hause kommen.
I think, he knows you're talking.
Magners merkt, wenn ich weine.
Ja, er spürt, dass du traurig bist.
Mommy's in trouble.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge, Schluchzen *
Ich habe Angst,
dass ich alles verliere.
Nein, du kannst uns nie verlieren.
Me and Magners.
(Wann Noëlle zurück nach
San Francisco kann, ist ungewiss.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Herzpochen *
Wir wussten sehr schnell,
dass wir zusammengehören.
Ja.
- Es stand gar nicht zur Diskussion.
Ich habe zu Beginn
schon etwas mit mir gerungen,
weil das nicht
zu meinen Plänen gehörte.
Ich wusste genau:
Wenn ich diesen Schritt gehe,
wird alles, alles anders.
Alles anders.
* Mediterrane Popmusik:
"Nour El-Ain" von Amr Diab *
# Habibi, habibi, habibi,
ya nour el-ain.
# Habibi, habibi ...
(Seit 23 Jahren gehen Corinne und
Wael schon miteinander durchs Leben.)
(Sie haben viele gute,
aber auch andere Momente erlebt.)
(Ich treffe die Zürcherin
und den Ägypter
an der Küste des Roten Meeres
in Scharm El-Scheich.)
Wow!
Gorgeous.
- Unbelievable! So schön!
Leider haben wir
kein so schönes Boot.
Ist das nicht eures?
- Das hätte ich gerne.
Aber wir haben viele
gute Erinnerungen an dieses Boot.
Die Kinder
tobten auf den Segeln herum.
Wir verbrachten viel Zeit auf See.
- Ja.
Wo habt ihr euch kennengelernt?
Dort drüben.
Genau in diesem Hotel dort.
(Sie hatte eine leitende Stellung
in einem Fünfsternehotel,
er arbeitete als Notfallmediziner.)
Ich wusste nur, dass es im Hotel
jemanden mit blondem, schönen Haar
und langen Beinen gab.
Man nannte sie "Longlegs" -
"Langbein".
Eines Tages wurde Corinne sehr krank
und brauchte einen Arzt.
Da ich zu diesem Zeitpunkt
aber in Kairo war,
musste man ihr
einen anderen Arzt schicken.
Dann haben sie mir jemanden
geschickt. Es ging sehr schnell.
An der Tür gab man mir
zwei Tabletten.
"Nimm die morgens und abends,
dann wird es wieder gut."
Ich war relativ enttäuscht
von der Art,
wie man mich
an der Tür abgefertigt hatte.
Da habe ich - wie sagt man? -
einen complaint gemacht.
Du hast dich beschwert.
Das kam ihm natürlich zu Ohren
und er hat mich sofort kontaktiert
und sich entschuldigt.
Ja, so hat dann unsere Geschichte
ihren Lauf genommen.
Lerne: Es ist nicht immer gut,
wenn wir Schweizer das Gefühl haben,
wir müssen immer sagen:
"Es war schon recht."
Es kann sehr lohnenswert sein,
sich zu beschweren.
Auf den Putz zu hauen.
Man kann dabei
die Liebe seines Lebens kennenlernen.
* Lockere,
orientalisch angehauchte Musik *
Das Geheimnis
einer erfolgreichen Ehe ist:
"Nichts ist selbstverständlich."
Und: "Denke, bevor du redest!"
Respekt, natürlich.
Denken, bevor man redet,
ist auch ein Zeichen des Respekts.
Nimm dich selbst nicht so wichtig!
Nimm das Leben leicht!
Wir sind hier auf der Welt
nur zu Besuch.
Und habe zwei Badezimmer.
- Und zwei Badezimmer.
Seines und ihres.
An alle jungen Paare:
Wenn ihr es euch leisten könnt,
schaut,
dass ihr zwei Badezimmer habt!
This is a guaranteed success.
(Ja, diese beiden
können Beziehungstipps geben.)
(Schliesslich haben sie fast
ein Vierteljahrhundert Erfahrung.)
(Aber wann genau
fängt eine Liebesgeschichte an?)
(Bei Corinne und Wael
lässt sich das ganz genau sagen.)
Das war ganz am Anfang,
als wir uns kennengelernt hatten.
Wo seid ihr da?
Auf dem Dach
von guten Freunden von uns.
Da haben wir uns
zum ersten Mal geküsst.
Ja, da haben wir uns
Wie war es?
Bevor wir küssten, sagte ich:
Sie sagte: "Ich bin nicht der Typ,
der rumspielt."
"Das ist ernst für mich."
Ich sagte: "Verstanden.
Auch ich meine es ernst."
Dann küssten wir uns.
(Dieser Kuss war ein Versprechen,
das schnell
in eine Hochzeit mündete.)
(Einzig die ägyptische Bürokratie
konnte ihren Elan
kurzfristig stoppen.)
Es war ein langer
bürokratischer Prozess.
Schlussendlich
hatten wir 57 Stempel.
Und das heisst 57 Stempel
von 57 verschiedenen Leuten.
Und das Formular war so lang.
I remember, the paper was this big.
Und bei der tatsächlichen Hochzeit,
in diesem Büro,
machte der Mann das grosse Buch auf
und sah, dass Wael Arzt war.
Da machte er das grosse Buch
wieder zu
und setzte sich so an den Tisch
und sagte:
"Doktor, ich habe immer so
unglaubliche Kopfschmerzen."
"Können Sie nicht schauen,
was ich habe?"
Während eurer Hochzeit sagte er:
"Kannst du schnell schauen,
was mit mir ist?"
Ja.
- Hast du ihn untersucht?
Natürlich
spielte ich bei diesem Spiel mit.
Ich stand auf,
stellte mich hinter ihn ...
Er schrieb ihm sogar noch auf,
was er machen musste.
Ich zeigte ihm
eine Entspannungsübung.
Dann öffnete er
das grosse Buch wieder und sagte:
"Glückwunsch.
Sie sind jetzt verheiratet."
Oh, so herzig.
- Ja.
(Ein glückliches Paar,
zwei kleine Kinder -
ein Sohn und eine Tochter -
und ein Leben
in einem Ferienort unter Palmen.)
(Perfekter kann man sich das Glück
kaum vorstellen.)
* Sanfte Musik *
(Aber irgendwann
macht sich der Alltag breit -
und zwar überall
und in jeder Familie.)
Die Welt geht in Scharm El-Scheich
in die Ferien,
aber Notarzt Wael hat hart gearbeitet
und war kaum zu Hause.
Einmal wollte ich meinen Jungen
vom Kindergarten abholen,
aber er weigerte sich,
mit mir mitzukommen und weinte.
Das war der Weckruf.
Ich war ein Fremder für ihn.
"Mein Gott!", sagte ich mir.
"Was mach ich da überhaupt?"
Immer dieses Kommen und Gehen.
Ich fragte mich:
"Will ich das auch in Zukunft so?"
Nein.
Ich wollte unbedingt mehr Zeit
mit meiner Frau
und meiner Familie verbringen.
Es gibt wohl viele Frauen,
die sagen würden:
"Deswegen
habe ich dich nicht geheiratet."
Das verstehe ich.
Darum sage ich auch,
dass Corinne unglaublich ist.
Bei ihr kommt alles zusammen:
Belastbarkeit, Stärke,
und gleichzeitig
ist sie sanft und liebenswürdig.
Can you take both?
- Ja.
(Und Mut zum Risiko hat sie auch.)
(Corinne sagte sofort Ja,
als Wael einen Neuanfang vorschlug.)
Ach, wie schön.
(Ein zweites Studium
zum Chiropraktiker in den USA.)
(Die beiden liessen alles zurück,
was sie in Ägypten aufgebaut hatten,
und gingen mit ihrer Familie
nach Chicago.)
* Herzpochen *
Unsere beiden Kulturen
sind unterschiedlich.
Ich würde nicht sagen,
dass sie zueinander passen,
aber die Unterschiede
erweitern unseren Horizont.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmusik *
(Bei Fabienne und Francis in Hawaii
sieht das Leben auf den ersten Blick
immer nach Ferien aus.)
What do you want to eat?
Do you feel like eating shrimps?
Can I have
a garlic shrimp plate, please?
(Der Monteur
mit den philippinischen Wurzeln
und die Glarner Sachbearbeiterin
geniessen ihren freien Tag.)
Er mag gerne Fleisch und Fisch.
Wenn es heiss ist,
mag ich lieber Früchte.
Darum ... Ja.
(Es gibt im Alltag einige Punkte, in
denen sie nicht einer Meinung sind,
aber diese Unterschiede
bringen einen weiter, finden sie.)
Ich habe aufgehört,
Konserven zu kaufen.
Mit Essen aus der Dose
bin ich aufgewachsen,
weil es günstiger
und einfach zuzubereiten war.
Fabienne hat mich überzeugt,
dass das ungesund ist.
Das ist eins der Dinge, die ich in
meinem Leben für sie geändert habe.
Aber Spam esse ich immer noch.
Dosenfleisch ist köstlich.
(Auch Fabienne lernte von Francis.)
Wenn wir irgendwo hingingen,
waren wir immer zu spät dran.
Ich als Schweizerin
bin gerne pünktlich.
Wenn es mir wichtig war,
sagte ich ihm einfach:
"Heute on Swiss time."
Das hat funktioniert.
Anfangs machte es mich
manchmal rasend,
wenn ich bereit war
und noch 1 1/2 Std. warten musste.
Aber das lernt man mit der Zeit.
Es hat keine Eile,
etwas zu erledigen.
Wenn man an den Strand geht,
muss man nicht
zu einer bestimmten Zeit dort sein.
Der Strand wird immer da sein.
(So verschieden sie sind,
haben die beiden schnell gemerkt,
dass es wichtig ist, grosszügig
zu sein und Kompromisse einzugehen,
um miteinander glücklich zu werden.)
* Herzpochen *
* Es klingelt zweimal. *
Aggressives Klingeln.
Ah!
(Frau) Hallo!
- Vielen Dank!
Oh, jetzt habe ich Herzklopfen.
(Seit acht Wochen
sitzt Noëlle in der Schweiz fest.)
(Heute gibt es endlich Post
von der amerikanischen Botschaft.)
Wo ist mein Visum?
Ah! Es ist drin!
Jetzt geriet ich gerade in Panik,
weil ich das alte Visum
gesehen habe:
"Äh ...
Nein, das ist es aber nicht."
Ah!
Das war die ganze Zeit
so ein Stress
und jetzt ist es einfach so ... Ah!
Ich wusste nicht,
ob ich nach Hause kann -
zu meinen Dingen, meinem Freund,
meinem Hund, meiner Katze,
meiner Arbeit, meinem Leben,
weil irgendjemand ...
Man ist einfach fremdkontrolliert
und hat keinen Einfluss
auf irgendetwas.
Und jetzt
ist einfach gerade alles gut.
Ah!
Er wird sich mega freuen.
* Lockere Countrymusik *
Ich kann es immer noch nicht
glauben, dass sie kommt.
While I'm cleaning,
it gets closer and closer.
Ich weiss, was sie nicht mag:
Sie mag keine rosafarbenen Blumen.
Ich glaube, ich nehme Rosen.
Danke, einen schönen Tag noch!
Come on, buddy, let's go!
* Orientalisch angehauchte Klänge *
(Es ist 3.30 Uhr -
aber bei Habibs brennt schon Licht.)
... five, six, seven, eight.
* Er ächzt. *
* Heftiges Ausatmen *
It's the only time
I can do anything.
Das ist die einzige Zeit am Tag,
an der ich was machen kann.
Ich brauche den Sport,
um arbeiten zu können -
sonst verliere ich Energie.
(Wael ist 55 arbeitet mittlerweile
als Sportmediziner.)
(Er und seine Frau Corinne
haben eine eigene Praxis in Kairo.)
Oh, mamma mia.
Und das so früh.
Es ist cool, dass er
so früh aufsteht und das tut.
Er zieht es wirklich immer durch,
aber ich kriege das nicht hin.
Heute liege ich
relativ gut in der Zeit,
darum gibt es einen leckeren Kaffee.
Mmh.
Nein. Nein.
* Wael lacht. *
Erwischt. Guilty.
Sorry.
Ich dachte,
für eine kleine Pfeife wäre Zeit.
You smoke in the morning.
- A small pipe.
Ich brauche sie nach dem Training.
- Das kannst du nicht machen.
Sie hasst es.
Schatz, es ist 6 Uhr früh.
Corinne und Wael leben allein.
Die beiden Kinder sind
zur Ausbildung in der Schweiz.
(Das Haus der Habibs ist gemietet.)
(Kaufen wäre viel zu teuer,
sagen sie.)
(Sie wohnen im Süden Kairos
in einer gatet community -
einer bewachten Siedlung.)
(Davon gibt es
in der 20-Mio.-Stadt viele.)
* Sanfte, orientalische Musik *
(Es sind nur wenige Kilometer
zur Praxis,
aber die beiden
nehmen immer ein Taxi.)
Am Anfang fuhren wir selbst,
doch es wurde zunehmend
zu einem Kampf.
Momentan herrscht noch kein Verkehr,
aber in 1 Std.
wird es wirklich hart.
Wir wollen entspannt
in der Praxis ankommen.
* Corinne lacht. *
* Sanfte, orientalische Musik *
(Seit zehn Jahren leben sie
in der Hauptstadt Ägyptens.)
(Davor waren sie
vier Jahre lang in den USA.)
(Wael studierte in Chicago
Chiropraktik.)
* Sanfte, orientalische Musik *
(Die Rollen in der Praxis
sind klar verteilt.)
(Corinne macht die Organisation,
Wael kümmert sich um die Patienten.)
Ready to tango?
- Schau, er trägt die Einlagen.
Das sieht gut aus.
And he walks good.
(Das Konzept der beiden kommt an,
auch wenn ihre Öffnungszeiten
für Ägypten nicht normal sind.)
Wir setzten uns das Ziel,
wirklich am frühen Morgen anzufangen
und es durchzuziehen.
Viele sagten uns:
"Das könnt ihr vergessen."
"Keiner kommt so früh am Morgen."
Am Anfang öffneten wir um 8.30 Uhr,
jetzt sind wir bei 7.15 Uhr.
Down and out, up and in.
(Als Chiropraktiker behandelt Wael
Patientinnen mit Problemen
am Bewegungsapparat
und an der Wirbelsäule.)
Very good.
Let's do it on the other side, too.
So, same thing.
* Knacken *
(Als Wael seine Praxis
vor zehn Jahren eröffnete,
war er einer der ersten hier
mit dieser Spezialisierung.)
(Heute kommen die Patient/-innen
aus dem gesamten arabischen Raum.
Comment allez-vous?
* Arabische Wortfetzen *
* Beschwingte Rockmusik *
(Heute - endlich - kommt Noëlle an.)
Ich bin ein wenig aufgeregt.
Aber wenn ich endlich dort bin,
ist alles gut.
(Lange, lange wussten sie nicht,
wann sie sich wiedersehen würden.)
(Und jetzt
geht plötzlich alles schnell.)
Oh, Magners, come in here!
Come in here!
Now, we're back together.
He didn't even eat his breakfast,
he was so nervous.- Oh no!
He could tell something's happening.
- Oh.
* Herzpochen *
Unser Zuhause ist im Moment Sambia.
Wir schauen, wie wir uns wohlfühlen.
Wir wollen aber sicher auch einmal
in die Schweiz gehen.
Wenn die Familienplanung
im Raum steht,
ist es mir auch wichtig,
dass die Kinder
eine Schweizer Schulbildung haben.
* Eindringliche
afrikanisch wirkende Musik *
(Sambia liegt im südlichen Teil
von Afrika. Das Land ist arm.)
(Über die Hälfte der Menschen
muss mit weniger als 2 ¤ am Tag
auskommen.)
(Vom Kanton Thurgau nach Kabwe -
grösser könnte der Kontrast
fast nicht sein.)
(Für Myriam ist das Alltag.)
(Aber als Weisse fällt sie auf,
wenn sie in den Strassen von Kabwe
unterwegs ist.)
* Leises Gespräch *
* Ein Kind quengelt und weint. *
* Ein Mann ruft etwas. *
01:05:30,160 --> 01:05:30,080
Come!
I thought he was mad, but he's not.
- Me too.
Ich nehme meistens Chris
oder sonst jemanden mit,
weil ich mich manchmal
nicht zu 100 % wohlfühle,
weil man schnell ...
Weil man halt einfach auffällt
und nichts dagegen tun kann.
Es ist für mich einfacher,
wenn ich jemanden dabeihabe.
Wenn mich jemand anspricht,
der kein Englisch kann,
weiss ich dann wenigstens,
worum's geht.
Ich verstehe Myriam
jetzt viel besser,
weil ich dasselbe
in der Schweiz erlebt habe.
Auch wenn mich die Leute
nicht ansprachen,
spürte ich,
dass sie viele Fragen hatten.
(Nicht nur die Hautfarbe,
auch das Geld
ist im Alltag
immer wieder ein Thema.)
(Als Filmer und Fotograf
verdient Chris genug
für ein gutes Leben in Sambia,
aber als Schweizerin kommt Myriam
aus ganz anderen
finanziellen Verhältnissen.)
It's okay, okay.
The fact, that she's
from Switzerland, she's  ...
In der Schweiz lernt man schon von
klein auf, wie man Geld sparen kann.
Hier ist das anders.
Wegen der schlechten
wirtschaftlichen Lage
leben die Menschen
von der Hand in den Mund.
Ich wuchs damit auf,
die Dinge zu schätzen, die ich habe.
Sicher hat Myriam mehr Geld als ich,
aber das
spielt für mich keine Rolle.
Als Mann bin ich in der Lage,
dafür zu sorgen,
dass es immer genug zu essen gibt
und es ihr auch sonst
an nichts fehlen wird.
Ich habe nie stark
auf die Rollenverteilung geachtet.
Als ich mit dem Studium begann,
konnte ich mir vorstellen,
nicht zu Hause und Mami zu sein,
sondern dem Job nachzugehen
und vielleicht
mehr zu verdienen als der Mann.
Darum war das
für mich nicht komisch,
auch bevor ich ihn kennenlernte.
Es ist normal und okay für mich.
(Die beiden gehen
mit viel Gelassenheit und Zuversicht
ihrer gemeinsamen Zukunft entgegen.)
(In wenigen Tagen
wollen sie heiraten.)
* Herzpochen *
Ich dachte nicht wirklich
an Konsequenzen.
Ich hatte nur Augen für Corinne
und ihren Charakter.
Passen wir zusammen?
Wird es eine Erfolgsgeschichte sein?
Jede Herausforderung
zeigte umso mehr,
dass wir
füreinander geschaffen sind.
* Rhythmische,
arabisch angehauchte Musik *
(Dass Kairo
mal ihr Zuhause sein würde,
hätte sich Corinne nicht träumen
lassen, als sie Wael kennenlernte.)
(Kairo ist die grösste Stadt
auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent.)
(Sie ist faszinierend,
laut und chaotisch.)
(Nach einem langen Tag
in der Arztpraxis
haben Corinne und Wael Feierabend.)
(Sie führen mich zu einer Bar mit
Blick auf das Wahrzeichen Ägyptens.)
Schau mal! It's amazing.
- Sieh dir das an.
Unbelievable.
- Even for you?
Sure, of course.
- Of course.
(Die Pyramiden von Gizeh
sind über 4'500 Jahre alt.)
(Sie gehören zu den ältesten
Bauwerken der Menschheit.)
Wow, das ist ja Wahnsinn!
Interessanterweise glauben viele,
die Pyramiden stünden in der Wüste.
Dabei sind sie mittlerweile
direkt am Stadtrand.
Unfortunately a lot of things
are built here illegal.
Das ist alles ...
Sehr viel ist illegal. Right?
(Warum seid ihr überhaupt
nach Kairo gezogen?)
Ich glaube, dass der Nabel der Welt
am Mittelmeer liegt.
Die Kinder sollten die Wahl haben.
Stell dir vor,
sie haben in Kairo gewohnt,
in den Staaten gelebt
und sie kennen auch die Schweiz.
Es geht darum, eine umfassende
Persönlichkeit zu formen.
Ehrlich gesagt,
war es auch ein finanzieller Aspekt.
Warum?
- Wir lebten fast vier Jahre dort.
Wir waren blank.
Also pleite?
- Pleite, komplett.
Wir hatten keinen Rappen mehr.
- Weil er die Ausbildung gemacht hat?
Klar. Stell dir mal vor, wir gaben
unser gesamtes Erspartes auf.
Aber dann passierte etwas,
mit dem ihr nicht gerechnet hattet.
Drei Wochen nach eurer Ankunft
kam der Arabische Frühling.
Es gab eine Revolution, und man
wusste nicht, wo das hinführen würde:
Würde es einen Bürgerkrieg
oder eine neue Regierung geben?
Was war das für ein Moment?
Ich hatte in meinem Leben
noch nie so viel Angst.
V.a. in der Nacht. Wir schliefen
nicht mehr, weil wir Panzer hörten.
Wir wohnten neben einer Brücke.
Sie fuhren rauf,
und das klang wahnsinnig.
Wir waren immer angezogen.
Ich trug einige Schmuckstücke,
an denen ich sehr hänge.
Ich hatte meine Tasche neben
dem Bett und meinen Laptop dabei.
Wenn etwas passiert wäre, hätte ich
sie nur nehmen und losrennen müssen.
Auch die Kinder waren angezogen. Wir
schliefen drei Tage lang angezogen.
Das war ein seltsames Gefühl.
Ich fragte mich,
wozu ich bereit wäre,
um meine Familie zu verteidigen.
- Really?
Bist du gewillt,
jemanden zu verletzen
oder sogar noch weiter zu gehen?
I remember, you were very disturbed.
Ich merkte,
dass ich kein Problem hätte,
jemanden zu verletzen,
der meiner Familie etwas antun will.
Warum seid ihr trotzdem geblieben
und habt euch ...
Warum seid ihr nicht
in die Schweiz zurückgegangen?
Direkt danach verschob sich
die Macht zu den Muslimbrüdern.
Sie waren natürlich nicht
qualifiziert, ein Land zu führen.
A country isn't a grocery store.
Wir wussten,
dass es nicht lange gutgehen würde.
Nichts ist nachhaltig:
Es gab Stromausfälle. Der Mangel
an Wasser und Elektrizität.
Doch die Dinge änderten sich
dramatisch und sehr schnell.
Der Preis dafür war hoch.
Nun haben wir eine Militärregierung,
aber zumindest
konnten wir im Land bleiben.
(Politik ist ein heikles Thema.)
("Keep a low profile"
ist Corinne und Waels Motto -
"einfach nicht auffallen".)
* Sanfte,
orientalisch angehauchte Musik *
Ich sah dich nie
als typischen Amerikaner.
Du erscheinst mir eher europäisch -
wie du denkst.
Du bist weltoffen.
Ja.
Schweizer sind beim ersten Treffen
eher verschlossen.
Sie öffnen sich erst nach und nach.
So bist du überhaupt nicht.
Du bist von vornherein offen.
Diesbezüglich bin ich amerikanisch.
- Ja.
Das ist seltsam. Total gemischt.
* Lockere Musik *
(Wenn man in San Francisco lebt,
ist das Napa Valley nicht weit.)
(Hier gibt es nicht nur guten Wein,
auch die Landschaft
hat ihren eigenen Reiz -
besonders für jemanden, der aus
der Schweiz kommt, wie Noëlle.)
* Lockere Musik *
Is there any place
as flat in Switzerland?
(Noëlle und Matt - so jung sie sind -
machten schon viel gemeinsam durch.)
(Vor sieben Jahren haben sie
in einem Irish Pub in San Francisco
zum ersten Mal zusammen angestossen.)
(Aus der Ferienliebe
auf den ersten Blick
wurde eine Fernbeziehung
mit Höhen und Tiefen,
bis Noëlle schliesslich einen Job
als Kindergärtnerin gefunden hat
und in die USA ziehen konnte.)
(Und wie geht es weiter?)
Im Moment sind wir in der Beziehung
an einem Punkt,
wo ich nur
auf den nächsten Schritt warte,
sprich,
dass er die grosse Frage stellt,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Es hat auch schon Momente gegeben,
in denen ich dachte:
"Hey, du lässt dir
verdammt viel Zeit."
Aber wir wissen, dass er
ein sehr überlegter Mensch ist.
* Ballade: "Nothing's
Gonna Stop Us Now" von Starship *
# Let the world around us
just fall apart.
# Baby, we can make it
if we're heart to heart.
# And we can
build this dream together,
# standing strong forever,
nothing's gonna stop us now.
("Wir heiraten nicht
für eine Aufenthaltsbewilligung",
haben beide immer gesagt,
"sondern erst,
wenn wir uns wirklich sicher sind.")
(Mein Gefühl sagt mir,
dass es nicht mehr lange dauert.)
# Ooh, all that I need is you.
* Hupen *
(In der Millionenmetropole Kairo
ist der Verkehr im Alltag
ein Dauerthema.)
(Auch für die Schweizerin Corinne.)
* Hupen *
(Lachend) Das ist eine Challenge.
Sie kommen aus allen Richtungen -
von oben, unten, links, rechts.
Man muss sich
schon sehr konzentrieren.
Aber es ist spannend.
Es herrscht no law.
(Es gäbe schon Verkehrsregeln -
nur halten sich die wenigsten daran.)
(Gefahren wird wo es Platz hat -
und angehalten auch.)
Das nennt man double parking.
Man parkiert
das Auto so auf gut Glück,
in der Hoffnung,
dass niemand wegmuss.
(Corinne ist in Maadi unterwegs,
einem Vorort von Kairo,
in dem viele Expats wohnen.)
* Sie lacht. *
Oh mein Gott ... Das ist ...
Hier möchte man gleich
Vegetarierin werden. Wuah!
* Sie unterhalten sich
auf Arabisch. *
(Mit ihrem Arabisch könne sie sich
im Alltag durchschlagen,
aber für ein richtiges Gespräch
reiche es nicht, sagt Corinne.)
(Mit ihrem Mann Wael
spricht sie nur Englisch.)
Klar, würde ich wahnsinnig gerne
besser Arabisch sprechen,
aber ich finde es
eine schwierige Sprache. Und ...
So viele Leute
sprechen andere Sprachen,
da war es einfach für mich,
zurechtzukommen.
Aber ja, ich glaube, das ist
einer meiner grössten regrets,
dass ich die Sprache
nicht besser spreche.
* Sie sprechen arabisch. *
Bevor man in Ägypten heiraten kann,
muss man den Wert seiner Frau
angeben.
Danach bemisst sich die Gebühr,
die man zahlen muss.
Als Wert muss man
mindestens 25 Piaster angeben,
also ungefähr 25 Rp.
Dann kam er raus und ich fragte,
was er noch gemacht hätte.
Er sagte, er hätte noch
das Formular ausfüllen müssen
und den Preis angeben.
Da fragte ich ihn:
"Was hast du angegeben?
Wie viel wert bin ich?"
Und er sagte:
"Ich habe 25 Rp. hingeschrieben."
(Auch wenn Wael
viel mehr bezahlt hätte,
hätte sich die Investition
auf jeden Fall gelohnt.)
(Er und Corinne
sind seit 22 Jahren verheiratet
und haben zwei erwachsene Kinder.)
Hey, schau wer da kommt! Schau!
- Hey, monkeys!
How are you?
# Happy birthday to you!
- # ... to me!
Schön, euch zu sehen!
Ja, ja.
Soll ich ihm
einen Kuss geben von euch?
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
How's the weather over there?
(Noah und Cloe
sind für ihre Hotelfachausbildung
in der Westschweiz.)
(Cloe) Foggy.
- Foggy and snowy.
Hallo zusammen!
Es ist sehr schön, euch mal zu sehen.
Sie schwärmen so von euch.
- Zu Recht.
Wenn ihr eure Eltern beschreiben
müsstet: Was für ein Paar sind sie?
Ich glaube, a little bit crazy,
but that's why it works.
Right?
- Yeah, crazy ...
Adventurous.
- Loving.
(Noah) Also ein richtiger Mix.
Ein grosser, grosser Mix, ja.
Ich hätte sie so gern hier.
So, what is the family language,
actually?
Erst sprecht ihr ein wenig deutsch,
dann wechselt ihr ins Englische.
Arabisch höre ich aber gar nicht.
Könnt ihr Arabisch?
Wir wissen zumindest,
wie man auf dem Markt Früchte kauft.
* Lachen *
Englisch ist die Familiensprache.
Und das liegt an mir.
Das Problem ist: Sie sprechen andere
Sprachen, die ich nicht verstehe.
Sie haben ihre Geheimsprache.
* Lachen *
So, you don't understand
the Swiss German?
Wenn ihr zusammen Schweizerdeutsch
redet, versteht Wael ...
No, not really.
Am Anfang dachte ich,
es wäre grossartig,
wenn sie auch
Arabisch lernen würden.
Stell dir vor:
Sie sprechen Englisch, Französisch,
Schweizerdeutsch,
Hochdeutsch, etwas Spanisch.
Und dann auch noch Arabisch.
Aber es erschien mir
ein riesiger Aufwand -
für die Kinder und auch für mich.
Ich war fast den ganzen Tag weg.
Wenn ich dann mal da war,
wollte ich nicht auch noch das
Zuhause in eine Schule verwandeln.
Sie waren ja schon tagsüber
auf der Internationalen Schule
und mussten dort mit
verschiedenen Sprachen klarkommen.
Sie wechseln die Sprache,
je nach Gesprächspartner.
Das ist fantastisch.
(Noch gibt es hier nicht viel mehr
als Sand und Beton.)
(Im Südosten Kairos
wird ein neues Wohnquartier
aus dem Boden gestampft.)
(Hier entsteht auch das künftige
Zuhause von Corinne und Wael.)
* Er spricht arabisch. *
Welches gehört euch?
Which one is yours?
Das mit dem weissen Rahmen.
- Okay.
(Den Kaufvertrag
für ihre neue Wohnung
haben die beiden vor drei Jahren
unterschrieben.)
Ding-dong! Wir kommen zu Habibs.
(Jetzt ist der Rohbau fertig
und die Arbeiter
fangen mit dem Innenausbau an.)
I love this wall.
Das Cheminée kommt hier rein.
- We'll have a fireplace.
Dort siehst du das Cheminée.
- Ein Cheminée in Ägypten?
Im Winter kann es am Abend
ziemlich kalt werden.
Ja, ja.
Aber es ist eher ein Ziercheminée.
Und das ist die Küche.
Alles ist total offen.
Und das ist hier komplett atypisch.
Hier haben die Leute
eine geschlossene Küche,
weil sie Angestellte haben.
Aha!
Das habe ich mir gar nie überlegt.
Die verstecken sie in der Küche.
- Ja, ja.
Die will man nicht sehen.
- Genau.
Aber ich will ...
Das ist meine Wohnung,
ich lebe hier und ich koche selber.
(Aus der Villa mit Garten und Pool
ziehen Habibs in eine Stadtwohnung.)
Das ist der nächste Schritt
auf eurer Reise als Paar.
Eure Kinder sind nun aus dem Haus.
Wie ist das für euch?
Das ist ein Neuanfang für uns beide.
... so even already thinking
of the ...
Kinderzimmer ...
Macht man Kinderzimmer?
Bringen wir alles
aus dem alten Haus hierher?
Wie machen wir das?
Wir wissen,
sie kommen nicht mehr.
Sie kommen einfach in die Ferien.
Und auch sie haben gesagt:
"Ihr wohnt dort.
Macht es so, wie ihr es wollt!"
"Wenn wir ein Bett haben
zum Schlafen, ist es uns recht."
Ist das auch schmerzhaft,
dieses Loslassen?
Ja, aber ich finde, jedes Loslassen
ist auch eine neue Chance.
Weisst du, irgendwie ...
Was sind die Herausforderungen
in diesem neuen Lebensabschnitt?
Es wird gut werden.
Auch gar nicht viel anders
als jetzt.
Wir ziehen hierher
in unser neues, kleines Paradies.
Wir werden hier sein,
auf Reisen gehen, die Kinder sehen
und dann zurückkommen
und weiterarbeiten.
Ich finde das ziemlich befriedigend.
* Ruhige Musik *
(Auf einem Segelschiff
auf dem Roten Meer
habe ich Corinne und Wael
kennengelernt.)
(Auf einer Feluke auf dem Nil ver-
abschiede ich mich von den beiden.)
* Sanfte Musik *
* Herzpochen *
Wenn ich euch in fünf
oder zehn Jahren wiedertreffe:
Wo wird das sein?
Vielleicht in Las Vegas,
man weiss nie.
Who knows?
- Warum nicht?
Auf jeden Fall
in einer neuen Wohnung.
Bei einem neuen Projekt,
einer neuen Idee.
Wichtig ist, dass wir zusammen sind.
- Ja, wir sind offen für alles.
Wo immer das Boot uns auch hinführt.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Herzpochen *
In einer Beziehung sein,
oder in einer Ehe sein,
ist ja sonst schon nicht einfach.
Man muss sich umgewöhnen.
Man kann nicht mehr einfach
selber Entscheidungen treffen.
Und dann sind es vielleicht
keine einfachen Entscheidungen,
weil die andere Person
eine ganz andere Einstellung hat -
vom Hintergrund, von der Kultur her.
Die kulturellen Unterschiede
und Herausforderungen
werden immer da sein.
Es lohnt sich aber,
einen Schritt weiter zu gehen
und voneinander zu lernen.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich die Kultur
komplett verstehen werde,
aber ich weiss,
ich werde Myriam verstehen.
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmusik *
(Auch das ist Sambia.)
(Eine Natur wie aus dem Bilderbuch.)
(In dieser Safari-Lodge etwas
ausserhalb der Hauptstadt Lusaka
geben sich Myriam und Chris
heute das Jawort.)
Im Moment fühlt es sich an, als wäre
es die Hochzeit von jemand anderem,
nicht meine eigene.
Es ist ein surreales Gefühl.
Es ist noch nicht
zu mir durchgedrungen.
(Für das Fest haben Chris und Myriam
insgesamt 70 Leute eingeladen.)
(Myriams Eltern und Geschwister
sind schon vor ein paar Tagen
aus der Schweiz angereist.)
That will be great.
Oh, Mama Martha is here!
* Sie lachen. *
(Und die Mutter von Chris
kommt auch gerade an.)
How are you?
- I'm good.
Wir sind so glücklich,
dass du da bist.
Wir Mütter weinen immer.
(Hanspeter und Jeanette Ziörjen
kennen Mama Martha bereits.)
(Vor einem Jahr
machten sie Ferien in Sambia.)
(Jeanette) So, komm jetzt.
Wir haben noch 30 Min. Wir müssen
noch unsere Rede vorbereiten
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl, Schätzchen.
Ui, ui, ui, jetzt geht's los!
(Die Eltern von Myriam
haben die Hochzeit finanziert.)
(Die Familie von Chris könnte sich
ein solches Fest nicht leisten.)
Bei einer Hochzeit in der Schweiz
hat man auch Auslagen.
Das ist gar kein Problem für mich.
Aber ich möchte nicht -
wie soll ich sagen -
die Gönnerin sein, die kommt und
das Geld quasi nur so ausgeben kann.
Das will ich nicht.
Es ist ein Spagat,
wenn man aus der Schweiz kommt.
Wir haben alles. Wir leben im
Überfluss. Wir haben viel zu viel.
Hier haben sie gar nichts -
oder fast nichts.
Sie müssen jeden Tag
wegen dem Essen schauen.
Sie leben von der Hand in den Mund.
Ich glaube, das ist etwas, das
sehr schwierig zu überwinden ist,
auch familienintern.
Wie machen wir das
mit der Unterstützung?
Myriam und Chris sind ein Thema,
dazu kommt die Unterstützung
der Familie.
Nur ein Beispiel zur Hochzeit:
Es war eine Riesensache, dass sie
überhaupt passende Kleider hatten.
Für uns ist das keine grosse Sache,
aber für sie schon.
Wo bekomme ich weisse Hemden?
Wo bekomme ich die richtigen Schuhe?
Also, fangen wir so an:
"Das ist der Tag,
den der Herr gemacht hat."
Ich bin so nervös.
I'm so emotional.
Please, forgive me.
Ich kann es
immer noch nicht glauben.
Der Tag ist da.
Von diesem Tag haben wir geträumt.
Wow!
* Stimmengewirr *
Gott segne dich.
I love you so much.
(Und dann geht es los.)
(Zuerst kommen die Trauzeugen
mit dem Bräutigam Chris.)
* Sanfte Afro-Pop-Ballade:
"Extra Time" von Abel Chungu Musuka *
* Jubel *
(Dann hat die Braut Myriam
ihren grossen Auftritt.)
* Sanfte Klavierballade: "'Til Death
Do Us Part" von Brian Nhira *
I, Christopher Mubengwa ...
- I, Christopher Mubengwa ...
... take you, Myriam Ziörjen ...
- ... take you, Myriam Ziörjen ...
... to be my wedded wife.
- ... to be my wedded wife.
I, Myriam Ziörjen ...
- I, Myriam Ziörjen ...
... take you,
Christopher Mubengwa ...
... to be my wedded husband.
- ... to be my wedded husband.
In the presence of God,
I make this vow.
* Jubel und Applaus *
Myriam, für die Welt
bist du nur irgendjemand,
aber für jemanden bist du die Welt.
Und dieser Jemand bin ich.
Du bist mein Ein und Alles.
* Myriam spricht Bemba. *
* Jubel und Applaus *
(Myriam überrascht Chris
mit einer Liebeserklärung auf Bemba,
seiner Muttersprache.)
* Jubel und Applaus *
* Jubel *
Jetzt darfst du die Braut küssen.
* Lautes Kreischen *
* Fröhlicher Afro-Pop-Song *
(Gefeiert wird
bis tief in die Nacht.)
(Wie sehen sie ihre Zukunft?)
Mit Babys haben wir es nicht eilig.
Ich möchte die Zeit
mit meiner Frau geniessen.
Vielleicht auch reisen.
Wir brauchen noch Zeit miteinander.
Wenn Kinder da sind,
geht es v.a. um sie.
Zusammen wachsen,
zusammen Dinge erleben.
Ja, und auch das Leben geniessen.
Das Leben rast manchmal
an uns vorbei.
* Sanfter Popsong: "How Long
Will I Love You" von Ellie Goulding *
# As long as stars are above you.
(Die Liebe kennt keine Grenzen.)
(Und sie fragt auch nicht
nach dem Pass.)
(Sie nimmt uns an der Hand und ...
... überrascht uns immer wieder.)
* Rhythmischer Afro-Pop: "Marry You"
von Diamond Platnumz feat. Ne-Yo *
# When I look at you.
# I see the air of every flavoury.
# Sio mfupa mwenzio kibogoyo
utanitesa honey.
# I want to marry you.
- # Ooh lalalala, ooh lala.
# Aah,
twende kwa Mama Papaa, yoo oh.
# Oh, I want to marry you.
- # Ooh lalalala, ooh lala.
# I want to marry you.
- # Ohh lalalala, ohh lala.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Ph. Schlatter, M. Hoss, D. McMinn,
* Herzpochen *